[Musik]
nach dies sieht toll aus
vielen dank bitte ich möchte nicht dass
du unbedingt nach raus gehst du
ausprobieren und serien alle menschen so
gastfreundlich aber in deutschland auch
ich habe den eindruck dass viele
verhaltensregeln sehr ähnlich sind
er musste nico frage er ist der experte
ich möchte darum die frage nach der
familie
ich habe gelesen dass es höflich zu
fragen wie es der familie geht wenn man
die familie kennt ja aber es ist toll
dass du dich in form ist hass und vielen
dank für das tolle essen
bis bald danke heimann du das ist ja
wohl glasklar leider nicht ist das sogar
ziemlich kompliziert